with reaction senator lindsey graham won
by a big margin
by the way the polls were off in your
race by about 15 points as well
not a single poll predicted susan
collins would win and she won by seven
yeah mainstream media polling is
designed to suppress republican votes
i won by 11 susan won by seven or eight
mitch went by 21.
it's a game they play with their polling
to depress the republican vote
but i'm here tonight to stand with
president trump he stood with me
he's the reason we're going to have a
senate majority my my race was
overwhelming
he helped senate republicans we're going
to pick up house seats
because of the campaign that president
trump won
i'm going to donate 500 000 tonight
uh to president trump's defense legal
fund i've been on your show
you've raised a ton of money for me your
audience was incredibly helpful to
lindsey graham.com
give to donaldjump.com so we'll have the
resources
to fight the allegations of wrongdoing
are
are earth-shattering it makes the carter
warrant page application
carter warrant carter page warrant
application look on the up and up
so senate republicans are going to be
briefed by the trump campaign
saturday and every senate republican and
house republican
needs to get on television and tell this
story